le droit de grève existe déjà la droite
grève doit être connue aussi mais non à
l'encadrement de la grève étudiante sous
aucune forme
quoiqu'en pense au leader étudiant le
droit de grève peut-il être légalement
reconnus et encadrée pour ce groupe de
la société vérification faite ce droit
n'est pas reconnue par la loi ni au
québec ni au canada ni même en france
pays souvent cité en exemple dans ce
pays le droit de grève des étudiants
s'inscrit plutôt dans les traditions
politiques le droit de grève n'est
reconnue au canada et au québec que pour
les travailleurs
par contre les experts consultés
s'entendent pour dire que l'assemblée
nationale du québec que le faire par
l'adoption d'une simple loi
il rappelle que des mouvements sociaux
pas nécessairement légaux à l'époque ont
souvent été à l'origine de changements
importants comme la grève de me dogville
de 1957 qui a mené à la reconnaissance
des syndicats du québec et le conflit à
united aircraft 1974-75 qui a mené à la
loi anti briseurs de grève au québec
si le gouvernement du québec
reconnaissait le droit de grève des
étudiants pour étayer leurs balises et
l'application comme par exemple en
imposant un vote secret là encore oui
par l'adoption d'une simple loi
les experts consultés estiment aussi que
l'université du québec à montréal
pourrait accorder et encadrer le droit
grève de ses étudiants par elle-même car
la loi sur l'université du québec
reconnaît son indépendance ici des
libertés chavaux réseau canada montréal